since the pandemic began last year
the whole united kingdom has been
engaged in a great
national effort to fight covid and
there's no doubt that in
fighting the old variant of the virus
our collective efforts
were working and would have continued to
work
but we now have a new variant of the
virus and it's been both
frustrating and alarming to see the
speed
with which the new variant is spreading
our scientists have confirmed this new
variant is between
50 and 70 percent more transmissible
that means you're much much more likely
to catch the virus
and to pass it on as i speak to you
tonight
our hospitals are under more pressure
from covid
than at any time since the start of the
pandemic
in england alone the number of coveted
patients in hospitals has increased
by nearly a third in the last week to
almost 27
000 and that number is 40 percent higher
than the first peak in april on the 29th
of december
more than 80 000 people tested positive
for covid across the uk
a new record the number of deaths
is up by 20 over the last week and will
sadly
rise further and my thoughts are with
all those
who've lost loved ones
with most of the country already under
extreme measures
it's clear that we need to do more
together to bring this new variant under
control
while our vaccines are rolled out
in england we must therefore go into a
national lockdown
which is tough enough to contain this
variant
that means the government is once again
instructing you to stay at home
you may only leave home for limited
reasons permitted in law
such as to shop for essentials to work
if you
absolutely cannot work from home to
exercise
to seek medical assistance such as
getting a coveted test
or to escape domestic abuse
the full details of what you can and
can't do will be available at gov
dot uk forward slash coronavirus
if you're clinically extremely
vulnerable we're advising you to begin
shielding again and you will shortly
receive a letter
about what this means for you
and because we now have to do everything
we possibly can to stop
the spread of the disease primary
schools
secondary schools and colleges across
england
must move to remote permit provision
from tomorrow
except for vulnerable children and the
children
of key workers everyone will still be
able to access
earlier settings such as nurseries
we recognize that this will mean it's
not possible
or fair for all exams to go ahead this
summer
as normal the education secretary will
work with off quo
to put in place alternative arrangements
we will provide extra support to ensure
that pupils entitled to
free school meals will continue to
receive them while schools are closed
and we will distribute more devices to
support
remote education i completely understand
the inconvenience and distress
this late change will cause millions of
parents and pupils
up and down the country parents whose
children were in school today may
reasonably ask
why we did not take this decision sooner
and the answer is simply that we've been
doing everything in our power
to keep schools open because we know
how important each day in education
is to children's life chances
and i want to stress that the problem is
not that schools are
unsafe for children children are still
very unlikely to be severely
affected by even the new variant of
covid
the problem is that schools may
nonetheless act as
vectors for transmission causing the
virus
to spread between households
today the united kingdom's chief medical
officers have advised that the country
should move to alert level 5
meaning that if action is not taken
nhs capacity may be overwhelmed
within 21 days of course
there is one huge difference compared
to last year we're now rolling out the
biggest vaccination program
in our history so far we
in the uk have vaccinated more people
than in the rest of europe combined with
the arrival today of the uk's own oxford
astrazeneca vaccine the pace of
vaccination
is accelerating i can share with you
tonight
the nhs is realistic expectations
for the vaccination program in the
coming weeks
by the middle of february if things go
well
and with a fair wind in our sales we
expect to have offered the first vaccine
dose to everyone
in the four top priority groups
identified
by the joint committee on vaccination
and immunization
that means vaccinating all residents in
a care home
for older adults and their carers
everyone
over the age of 70
all front-line health and social care
workers
and everyone who is clinically extremely
vulnerable
if we succeed in vaccinating all those
groups
we will have remu removed huge numbers
of people
from the path of the virus and of course
that will eventually enable us to lift
many of the restrictions
we have endured for so long
i must emphasize that even if we achieve
this goal
there remains a time lag of two to three
weeks from getting a jab
to receiving immunity and there will be
a further time lag
before the pressure on the nhs is lifted
so we should remain cautious
about the timetable ahead but
if our understanding of the virus
doesn't change dramatically
once again if the rollout of the vaccine
program
continues to be successful if
deaths start to fall as the vaccine
takes effect
and critically if everyone
plays their part by following the rules
then i hope we can steadily move out of
lockdown reopening schools
after the february half term and
starting cautiously
to move regions down the tiers i want to
say
to everyone right across the uk
that i know how tough this is and i know
how frustrated you are and i know that
you've had
more than enough of government guidance
about defeating this virus
but now more than ever we must
pull together you should follow the new
rules
from now and they will become law in the
early hours of wednesday morning
a parliament will meet largely remotely
later that day
i know that the devolved administrations
in scotland wells
and northern ireland share my conviction
that this is a pivotal moment and
they're taking similar steps
the weeks ahead will be the hardest yet
but i really do believe that we're
entering the last
phase of the struggle because with every
jab
that goes into our arms we are tilting
the odds
against kovid and in favor
of the british people and thanks to the
miracle
of science not only is the end in sight
but we know exactly how we will get
there
but for now i'm afraid you must once
again
stay at home protect the nhs
and save lives thank you all very much